can you kind of give me some of the
uh some of the game on your merch
because i feel like rappers who are
watching this
they like they might be able to get come
up on some game with what y'all are
doing in the merch game and
like what's the most y'all have ever
like what's the most you've made on a
merch drop in a month
not to be in your pockets but you know
for inspirational purposes
the most i ever made was like 400 000.
400k
on a on on a was it a hoodie was it a
shirt or whatever
shirts that [ __ ] is crazy mm-hmm 400
000 hell yeah did you you you
just did it i just did a merge drop a
couple days ago i know shout out those
hoodies are for the pyrex cities yup yup
go grab those joints fire
yeah i was so mad when i went to the
[ __ ] la show out here because the
only thing that was left was like
something you had for sale for 400
or something i was like [ __ ] man i think
it was like a jacket or something or
something like
right right [ __ ] butcher like [ __ ]
apron or something
damn yeah it was kind of crazy man